vice president your excellencies fellow
aldermen ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the Guildhall I'm especially pleased to
welcome vice president of the European
Commission mr. Dombrowski's to the city
today unfortunately the budget debate in
the Latvian Parliament has kept the
Prime Minister Caryn's busy in Riga but
we look forward to welcoming him to one
of our future discussions today we are
here to talk about sustainability a
topic which has topped and tailed my
first week in office on Tuesday morning
I attended a plastic free city event at
Rothschild & Co in the city encouraging
City businesses to rethink the way they
use plastic and today I'm here with you
to understand what more the financial
sector can do to create a more
sustainable world from the powerful
actions of young activists like Greta
Thames Berg to the devastating images of
melting IceCaps sustainability is an
emotive issue that has been hard to
escape but the climate change is much
more for media fanfare according to the
UN it is one of the most pervasive and
threatening crisis's of our time if
temperatures continue to increase we
risk creating an uninhabited world for
future generations for these reasons in
2016
175 world leaders signed the Paris
agreement committing to accelerating
action and investment to create a
low-carbon future in 2018 the European
Union took this a step further
promising to become the first major
economy to go climate neutral by 2050
under this plan emissions of greenhouse
gases after 2050 would need to be offset
by other means and earlier this year the
UK
match this push becoming the first major
economy to put into law its commitment
to be climate neutral by 2050
these were all encouraging steps
followed last week by another we were
delighted to hear vice president of your
announcement that the European
Commission will be looking into offering
banks regulatory relief for green
investments as the world's leading
financial center the city is equally
committed to leading the financial
services sector into a new era of
sustainable finance we want to work with
scientists learning what they need from
financial services and equally teaching
them the language of finance so we can
create workable sustainable products and
services and most importantly we want to
work internationally climate change
knows no borders and therefore it's
important we are encouraging economies
across the world to provide sustainable
financing we need to meet markets where
they're at earn and engage with the
sector's economies and jurisdictions
that are most in need of change using
everything in our arsenal to provide the
incentives needed to fund low or neutral
carbon solutions and assets one way will
one way we are working to do this in the
UK is through the green finance
Institute launched earlier this year the
Institute seeks to mobilize capital to
support the world's transition to a zero
carbon and climate resilient economy
working with international partners such
as Brazil and China and incorporating a
variety of stakeholders from economists
to members of government to scientists
we want to create truly viable and
sustainable financial solutions ladies
and gentlemen we are all aware that
mitigating against climate change will
be a tall task one which will require
the backing and support of every
individual every industry and every
nation of
cross our planet through being here
today you are demonstrating that support
signaling your commitment and more
broadly the financial sectors commitment
to creating a global low-carbon economy
thank you to the Latvian embassy
especially ambassador baby Bradley for
bringing us together today on behalf of
the city we look forward to working with
you all to find new financial solutions
to sustainable problems ensuring the
financial services sector is playing its
part in fighting the climate crisis and
securing the world's feature thank you
[Applause]
so it's now my great pleasure to
introduce her Excellency the Ambassador
from Latvia to the stage thank you thank
you very much good morning ladies and
gentlemen I would like first to thank
the Lord Mayor and the chair of the
policy committee of the city for the war
welcome second my best greetings for our
prime minister mr. Karen who was pleased
to know that it's not only the UK's
Parliament that sticks its food to the
ground but it was also Latvian
Parliament who actually instead of 24
hours took more than 48 hours to discuss
the budget law late last night it was
passed so we are good there is
government it's the same government the
the Prime Minister has asked me to make
a few remarks on behalf of Latvia and I
think this event is actually quite
perfect in seeing how the silos are
overcome I'll speak on behalf of a
government member of the of the EU we
will have Commission's vice-president
speaking on behalf of the institutions
and we have the private sector right
here and also the media and also some of
the civil society institutions so first
once we look at the wider picture of
course we all in the West understand
that we will have to manage some big
disruptions and these big disruptions
will have to be managed jointly by all
these sectors there is no more silo
thinking in this world when we look at
these major disruptions beat state and
non-state actors undermining rules-based
international system be technology beat
climate change beat migration they all
can only be managed together and we have
to come out on the other end if there is
the other end stronger more
knowledgeable and more United so the
answer on the Latin side is that we have
chosen to manage these disruptions
within the groups of like-minded stay
it's a EU NATO OSC dw2
WTO UN and other multilateral
institutions that are based on rules
that we have all voluntarily agreed upon
and are implementing in the best way we
think it's more efficient it scales our
serenity increases sovereignty scales
power and projects the joint interests
across the globe and again beat on
climate beat on technology beat on
deterring horde security threats trade
or adjusting taxation to modern day
realities all these tasks are better
achieved and projected globally within
these groups of states when we look
globally there are three big regulatory
areas three big regulators EU US and
China and it will be up to each and
every one to decide which of these areas
increases their scale increases they
power globally for us the answer is
clear on regulation its EU EU sets a
golden standards globally beat on
privacy beat on data and the new
Commission will have very important
initiatives in all this respect on
climate we have chosen to respond within
the EU by setting out ambitious aims
such as climate neutrality by 2050 while
underpinning these aims with concrete
policies and instruments shaping joint
national and global global response here
again overcoming the silos between the
private sector civil society academia is
crucial it in achieving success
governments alone will not be able to
succeed that he is among 16 member
states to support
twenty-five percent of the EU
multi-annual framework spending on
fighting climate change but we do
recognize that even more will have to be
spent in future our climate goals in
Latvia by 2030 significantly exceeds EU
average we are dedicated for our economy
to become carbon carbon neutral by 2050
it will cost a lot of money we know it
but there is no other way on green
finance we fully support Commission's
ambition and the work that has been done
thus far and in our view all three
components are equally important
environmental social and governance to
ensure sustainable development of our
economy but of all the economies
globally again this is setting the new
global standard obviously there are
practical challenges quantification of
climate risks unified criteria for what
to recognize as green projects terms
such as green washing will soon be an
everyday household name I guess in all
views the solution again is as unified
as possible EU standards taxonomy better
data exchange among Directors in
financial sector and b2g business to
government in Latvia lion's share of
businesses are small medium-sized
enterprises and in the financing they
rely solely or almost solely on banks
similarly to I guess many other EU
states so the financial sector will be
the driving force behind this change
already now we see that our financial
sector is a front-runner in introducing
new technologies and financing
mechanisms thus facilitating
sustainability for example a highly
successful green bond is being issued by
our national state financing agency
autumn demand in the Baltics
currently four significantly exceed
supply for this autumn has also been
actively issuing estou loans for
implementation of various green and
innovative projects filling the gaps of
conventional banks for example for
renewables and industrial sector solar
applications for energy generation for
energy efficiency lightning and
industrial efficiency today Latvia is a
leader in the U in energy efficiency
savings and that in turn has stimulated
also other industries becoming secondary
and tertiary beneficiaries for example
in passive and good housing smart Bo
economy these construction companies are
also active here in the UK or for
example on Internet of Things for
technology applications in energy
efficiency companies such as soft
Technica Easter Bay they are looking
also at the UK market going back and
looking at the stage where we are and in
conclusion let me be clear it is in the
interest of all that these disruptions
that give so many opportunities when
they are unregulated are guided in such
a way that strengthens the rule of law
and benefit our societies so standard
setting smart regulation bonafide
acomplia
is a way to proceed no rules no
accountability world will be the
opposite as we remember from financial
crisis just 10 years ago and while doing
that within the established groups of
states and institutions the private
sector needs to be on board business is
a major force for growth and impact
however they can also cause disruptions
the private sector needs to take
responsibility to put work with
governments and all other sectors to
create a workable governance sector
which ensures a shared responsibility
thank you for your attention and I would
like now to introduce mr. Valdez
Dombrowski
probably the most influential Latvian in
the world vice-president of the European
Commission and with the most substantive
portfolio
whenever the new Commission starts work
and he's been Prime Minister of Latvia
is one of the most respected politicians
in Latvia and led us out of the crisis
successfully so he is best placed also
for the whole of the EU to lead us in
the age of disruptions and come out
successfully from it
[Applause]
honorable lord mayor excellencies ladies
and gentlemen global politics tend not
to be simple or certain and we are
living in uncertain time we used to
think of the world moving on a path
towards greater democracy more open
markets and peaceful international
cooperation this is no longer the case
signal challenges face us from the more
insecure world right on our doorstep
trade tensions have escalated lowering
growth prospects for the global economy
so multi multilateral rules-based order
has been weakened the international
trading system has become less open
there are significant broader issues to
tackle as well most in Europe and
globally climate change digitization
aging societies does just to name a few
for the new European Commission the next
five years will be about managing these
issues effectively and fairly as
president-elect also from the line has
said Europe must lead the transition to
the carbon metal economy and new digital
world to achieve that economic social
and sustainable aspects all go hand in
hand for my own area of responsibility
this calls for a robust and risk
protected financial system underpinned
by healthy resilient national economies
and it means continuing our work in
deepening economic and monetary union in
the previous mandate we made significant
progress on the banking union and the
capital markets union both projects will
also be important priorities for the
next commission Europe's banking sector
is a much more solid footing than when
we face the last major financial crisis
a decade ago however now it's time to
complete the banking Union in particular
we need to agree on the common deposit
in sure
see that third pillar of the banking
Union to give it stronger and more
uniform insurance cover with a capital
markets Union we have secured agreement
for 11 out of 13 and proposals presented
by the Commission with a 12 likely to
come this year so one could say that the
basic building blocks are now in place
still xanex Commission plans to raise
its ambition and push further I think we
first need to refer and comes on further
on long term trades affecting where to
go
with where to go next with this flagship
project this is why the Commission will
bring together experts from industry and
civil societies to discuss these
elements in a high-level forum on
capital markets it should present
recommendations for the Commission in
its work for the next strategy for the
capital markets unit our small and
medium-sized businesses also need to see
same you completed auto often SMEs move
abroad to move abroad to scale up
because they find it difficult to go to
read to get market based financing here
in Europe as part of our work to make
sure that SMEs can access capital
markets everywhere in a single market I
will propose a new fund to help them to
go public supporting as a development of
local and regional capital markets will
remain a focus there is a basis for
deeper cross-border markets in Europe in
my own part of Europe Latvia and its
Baltic neighbours provide good example
they plan to create a pong Baltic
capital market as a pioneering project
which I warmly encourage the Commission
over already provides it with technical
support and strongly supports
cross-border initiatives such as this it
is also important to ensure the
integrity of Europe's financial sector
so that it cannot be undermined with
this in mind a president-elect from the
line has entrusted me with
leading the fight against money
laundering this is a task which I take
very seriously there's no place for
dirty money in Europe's banks while
Europe has some of the world's toughest
rules against money laundering we need
to strengthen supervision and
enforcement including across borders I
would see a lot of merit in conferring
specific anti Malan money-laundering
supervisory tasks and their coordination
to the EU body ladies and gentlemen as I
start I mentioned major challenges that
will top our political agenda for next
five years namely the green and digital
transformations how best to manage them
how to prepare our economies and
societies and how to make the most of
them for all but for all to benefit with
nobody left behind so now I will turn a
focus to the main focus of today
sustainable finance the EU is a global
leader in this area
the first erudition to pass hard law to
incentivize capital flows to green and
sustainable projects to finance the
transition to the climate natural
economy Europe's needs Europe needs
massive investment trillions of euros
over the next decades we will need both
public and private funding to pay for
everything from small-scale energy
efficiencies and Eno to low carbon
transport systems to large sustainable
investment projects the new commission
will draw up a sustainable Europe
investment plan to unlock 1 trillion
euros of sustainable investment over the
next decade to stimulate private
investment we should create right
regulatory incentives we have also
incorporated sustainability across all
policy areas in the EU s next
long term budget from 2021 to 27 which
we will use to also to leverage private
investment so at least 25% of EU budget
should contribute to sustainability
goals we'll also work with european
investment bank so that by 2020
20:25 at least half of its financing
will be dedicated to climate action
projects double what it is now on the
regulatory side we have agreed
disclosure rules for financial market
operators and also climate benchmarks we
are moving quickly with negotiations for
an EU classification system or taxonomy
to define which economic activities are
sustainable soon we'll start preparing
another set of green finance initiatives
this could include incentivizing tools
like green mortgage loans and expanding
se eu like eco liable to financial
products we will work on EU green bond
standards which could support local and
regional authorities and also SMEs to
issue bonds to assist in setting up
sustainable projects then on the
reporting side will propose measures in
the EU s-- non-financial reporting
directive and ask companies to give
sufficient and reliable information on
sustainability risks and opportunities a
transformation of the scale will affect
everyone and cause immense change in our
societies but it must not come as a cost
of the most vulnerable
it must be socially fair transition
without increasing poverty inequality or
social exclusion who support this
mozzies most affected by the green
transformation sorry new just transition
fund Europe faces another transformation
that is already well underway digital
transformation it has major effect on
financial services as we know them today
financial innovation and digitization of
financial services are a priority given
the huge potentials that new
technologies bring to the financial
sector for example while by giving
consumers better and faster access to
finance we will present a new strategy
for Europe to get the best out of
FinTech
and to compete globally as we remove
regulatory barriers between countries of
course we'll make sure to address risks
related to consumer protection money
during an terrorist financing data
protection to give just some examples
ladies and gentlemen I hope I have given
you a flavor or from the European
Commission's perspective of what the
next five years may hold for Europe's
financial sector particularly for
sustainable finance when it comes to
considering knowns and unknowns after
the point we can prepare but as ever we
have to be ready for unexpected and its
impact there is still uncertainty about
brexit let me be clear
the UK's departure is a loss for the EU
we share joint history and geopolitical
interests so we regret this decision but
we respected in this case it's important
to ensure that the withdrawal takes
place in an orderly way that is why I
was drawn agreement agreed between the
UK and between the EU and the UK
government in October is so important
and we hope ratification can happen soon
in my area of responsibility preserving
financial stability remains a top
priority and shared objective was for
the EU and the UK we have already work
it together to minimize financial
stability risks we have pressed and
continue press firms
to prepare for all outcomes we have
worked together under the chairmanship
of Mario Draghi and Mark Carney to
identify and mitigate stability risks we
bring related to BRICS it as you know
central clearing has been identified as
a clear systemic risk in a case of no
deal brexit the Commission addressed it
last year we are we are temporary
equivalents decision this will expire on
30th of March 2020 regrettably is a risk
to the financial stability has not yet
been fully removed because industry has
not so far fully prepared
therefore I intend to propose to renew
this time limited equivalents decision
beyond that date to prepare for any
eventuality
ladies and gentlemen resilience will
rename remains the name of the game for
the financial sector and we need a
resilient and stable financial sector
not only to finance innovation
investment and the competitive
competitiveness of our continent but
also to play its part in one of
history's biggest transformations the
transition to the carbon natural economy
thank you very much and I look forward
for the discussion thank you it's move
on to the panel the panel is it heads
the discussion financial service
industries perspectives on an EU action
plan for sustainable finance which the
Vice President has just outlined and may
I immediately say the Valdis is not only
the most important of Latvian in Latvia
probably in this Arab he's also
extremely important for the development
of green and sustainable finance
probably the most influential Latvian a
person in the world there too may
immediately pay tribute to the fantastic
work that the EU has been doing in this
space I would point out they have done
it with many UK colleagues alongside but
be that as it may
there's been really important work done
there and I think the EU as a driver
here with the uncertainties that exist
around the states and in China is a
really important leadership so well just
thank you very much indeed for that we
are going to talk about the perspectives
on the EU action plan I ought to
introduce myself sorry it says here
introduce yourself my name is Roger
Gifford I chair the green finance
Institute which the Lord Mayor refer to
earlier this is our new Institute set up
this summer to act as the primary
interface between public and private
sectors to find commercial solutions to
- and to change in particular around
green finance in the sustainable
sustainability area so it's a very
exciting new venture dr. Ian Murray
Thomas is its first chief executive at
Capital Markets banker from Barclays
Bank and we are optimistic for what it
can achieve in exactly the areas wildest
that you wish to see promoted so may I
ask the stage immediately ambassador by
thank you very much for your earlier
talk and to Rebekah self and to Stefan
Herter to help us in our discussion
around this subject
asking you you are the CFO of the finest
at HSBC HSBC is a absolute leader in the
area of sustainable finance and what do
you think about this new initiative that
the vice president has been promoting
well thank you and thank you for having
me here today
it's may be a few comments firstly
sustainable finance huge opportunity to
for growth and very much welcome the
initiative being announced today from an
HSBC perspective sustainable finance is
now 40 billion u.s. dollars that's since
early 2017 and it covers a number of
different areas green bonds which have
heard about sustainable development
goals and impact funds and I think this
is a really big area for a number of
different corporates those we bank and
across the EU but it's not without
challenges and some of the challenges
which have already been touched on
relate to data consistent definitions
and disclosures and in this respect the
taxonomy which we've heard about already
will be helpful and I'm having those
consistent definitions which we can all
work towards is something to be welcomed
when we look through our own corporates
that we lend to we do see some of those
gaps and particularly with carbon data
and greenhouse gas emissions data and if
we are to achieve the Paris agreement
collectively there are really key
initiatives like the climate related
financial disclosures or T CFD which
were also really important and supported
by Mark Carney and lots of work by the
Bank of England so welcome the
initiatives now at characterize
sustainable finance as progress but lots
more to do thank you very much well
that's optimistic and yet also ambitious
as
and you are the global head of ESG at
Allianz Global Investors I think you've
been active in this space since at least
the very first global equity
sustainability fund in 1999 so all this
stuff this amazing amount of revolution
that we're currently having around green
finance it's a rather old hat for you
isn't it what do you think about these
latest developments mainstreaming
sustainable finance surprised I guess
everyone who's been active in that area
for a long time and and and I have a
couple of different heads so it's global
head of ESG I'm in charge of integrating
sustainability into our investment
strategies from Alliance global
investors and it's become mainstream and
we do that and like many others we need
to improve financial performance and
ideally also to achieve a real-world
impact to improve environment and social
on the other hand you know the other hat
I have as a member of the technical
expert for sustainable finance signal
that has been sent out by the
sustainable funding section plan has
been enormous and also by a lot of
initiatives like here in Britain so I
think for me it's important to see that
it covers the full value chain you know
it starts with a corporate from the
corporate issue side climate data is a
key topic but also a lot of other
sustainability data to be honest it goes
to the acid oh and are like pension
funds those with a long-term investment
perspective insurance companies it goes
to data providers benchmark providers it
goes to the point of sales so as you may
have heard starting potentially q1 2021
at the point of sales and I've a bank
but also in the institutional States you
have to have a compulsory question in to
you whether the client has a
sustainability preference and our
clients or distributors are already
discussing heavily with us how to
prepare for that and it's a big
opportunity so I think it's an
opportunity and my point is it's an
opportunity to build growth to build
wealth for everyone and
and that's that's not to be
underestimated I mean it gets
complicated doesn't it I mean what is a
wonderful language and one of the
discussion one level when it comes down
to the actual detail required to make
real change in society it gets
complicated I think the the on the one
hand I think what is what needs to be
done is to simplify so perfection is the
enemy of the good I think you know you
can always find problems issues
challenges in whatever you do and this
is something new you know we're talking
about a massive transformation of the
economy the you and Britain aim for
carbon neutral economy the you by 2050
that means that is a massive effort
needed in the real economy sector to
change business strategy to prepare to
innovate and I think here I would step
back from complication more to
opportunity and point everybody in the
real industry that there's an
opportunity so for British companies for
Europe in continental European companies
innovating in low-carbon technology
which needs strong innovation there is a
global market waiting for you and for
many other sustainability products
perhaps some ambassador this is exactly
what you were pointing to as the need
for a framework and the need for kind of
guidance from the very top in this area
can you can you talk to us a little bit
about the taxonomy and the timing for
that and the and when we're going to see
the kind of the hard hard principled
hard guidelines hard regulation even
come into that come into the system yeah
so as regards our work on taxonomy
taxonomy has been one of the three
legislative proposals which we put
forward in a context of our current
sustainable finance action plan so the
proposals on benchmarks and disclosures
are already agreed and currently we are
at I would say advanced stage of
negotiations on taxonomy and I hope that
agreement between EU colleges letters
can be reached
this year well to be clear what we are
currently talking it's I'll say
governance framework of the taxonomy and
once he held his governance framework of
in place will help them to put out the
actual taxonomies but the way we have
organized our work was not to have it
all sequential and you know losing time
on this in a sense we had been preparing
in parallel so we had mr. Howe technical
expert group working on number of
elements of our sustainable finance
action plan including on taxonomy so I
would say our singing of the taxonomy is
already fairly developed so once we have
government a framework on place we will
be able to move forward with the actual
taxonomy because lots of preparatory
work has already been done
there is one risk which I would also
mention which was also mentioned that
perfect is enemy of the good
so what we should avoid the scenario is
that now we try to create some kind of
super taxonomy covering all possible
areas and war all aspects we need to
start gradually and then move forward so
the intention is to start first with a
climate mitigation taxonomies and then
we can expand in other areas for example
technical expert group has identified
six environmental areas like climate
mitigation climate adaptation circular
economy marine ecosystems by diversity
to mention some potentially we can move
into social and governance areas but the
important thing is not to try to create
it all now also as we can find out
ourselves three years down the road
still discussing it all
but actually to get going now and then
evolve our sinking and they've all
developed different economies in a
gradual way but already with climate
communication taxonomy would provide
much-needed clarity for the financial
sector which then would enable toot also
for a retail sector because based on
this we can also work for example as I
was mentioning on EU eco label on
financial services we can set Greenbaum
standards more clearly and to avoid
green washing in more general so to
summarize I'm hopeful that we can reach
political agreements till this year and
then we are able to start putting out
taxonomies actually fairly soon so maybe
first course of next year we should see
something hard coming into practice yes
that's as we tend to say in commissions
that's ambitious but realistic I think
weather should be realistic rather than
ambitious anyway but notice it's very
good to hear I mean I think the it's
it's fair to say the EU has been a
leader in the field of greening finance
China has been extraordinarily vocal and
active and yet we know also there's huge
energy demands which require Brown fuels
still being used there the United States
I think a huge amount is happening
there's a lot happening in individual
states and particularly New York
California and all over there so turning
to away from coal towards natural gas
but also towards wind farm and and solar
so there's a revolution happening there
but the senior levels of the United
States are not currently playing the
gate the rhetoric game if you like there
there are certainly also look as though
they may be withdrawing from from Paris
agreement what's your what's your
reaction to that and just as a kind of
gut reaction well first of all if we
talk sustainable finance of course it's
important that this is not only EU
effort but its global effort so after
all EU produces only around 9% of the
global emissions so clearly we need to
get a rest of the world on board as
that's why you
launched this initiative on the
international platform of sustainable
finance to agree with other restrictions
and to coordinate our approach to avoid
if you know if you want market
proliferate more market fragmentation
avoid different standards in different
countries which may be conflicting so to
the extent possible we need a
coordinated approach so that's why last
months we launched international
platform on sustainable finance it's at
this stage so it's EU representing 28
countries and it's Argentina Canada
Chile
China India Kenya and Morocco and it's
open for other countries to join so
we're working with other countries which
potentially will be joining this
international platform on sustainable
finance so well as you see China is on
board with this initiative u.s. is not
on board because yes we know what is
approached currently of the US president
on in this matter
but still we see lots of interests from
US states from cities which are willing
to do their part in fighting the climate
change so one can say that it's also in
case of us the case is not lost even so
central government is not interested
there are states and cities which are
doing their part
ambassador grouse q from your from your
perspective sitting here in London
observing what UK has been doing in the
green space and what the even forgetting
about the weather brexit happens or not
or what it's forgetting that direction
what what do you think of the main wins
for the EU in playing a global
coordination role it going to be
possible to get it become of them and us
well BRICS it is a disruption in this
respect because of course you know when
we speak about the scale you know of
projection of power of the EU globally
under standards of course you
kay comes as an important player with
MCU both with its knowledge with its
with its number of people with its
company isn't everything but for Latvia
I think all three elements of
sustainable finance are important when
we look at regulation globally and
cooperation globally so not only you see
the green per se but also the
environment not only the environment per
se but also social and governance
standards and I think that will be the
challenge with some other countries and
some other regions outside of Europe so
and there obviously the Commission is
the one leading the work and we do do
hopes we achieve the situation where
these standards are when when it's a
national issue of course we are small
and very flexible economy and our
interest is to have the regulation that
is smart and applicable where where our
SMEs can easily scale up without moving
anywhere just as vice-president side and
at the same time against the new
regulation does provide opportunities
instead of just fading so I think that
all that is how we see it I think this
this is a very interesting discussion
here about guidelines versus regulations
and actually I think you'll find many
market practitioners I'd like to ask
Rebecca and Stefan about this in a
moment would actually argue for first
restricted for stricter regulations as
opposed to guidelines which are convey
often be soft tea CFD is an example in
point why isn't tea CFD mandatory now
it'd be easier we're all in heading in
that direction and yet we're still in
the state of well it should be let's
let's let's be reasonable to the
corporates here let's not overburden
with costs in the tea CFD area so we
might come on to that in a moment but
well just before we move on I would very
much to the new international platform
on sustainable finance could you could
you mention a word about that because
I'm sure we'll all be involved in that
yeah well I already talked on this
international platform of sustainable
finance because that's important
initiative to move ahead with the
sustainable finance internationally so
it's already launched we Hal currently
EU on board of course we will how to see
what happens
post breaks it but certainly would like
that UK's and continues to be part of
the international platform of
sustainable finance as a third country
because there have been also many UK
players which have been very vocal in
area of sustainable finance to mention
just just one name
mark RT mark carney working on exactly
on the question you just raised on
disclosures on non-financial reporting
on this may be to add some points one of
the elements of our next action plan on
sustainable finance we will be looking
also at non-financial reporting
directive and indeed we are looking in
the direction to making those reporting
requirements more compulsory so to see
in which areas is justified to move from
guidelines non-binding guidelines as
it's now two more compulsory reporting
standards Thank You Stephan I'm going to
immediately turn it back to you and ask
you whether or not I mean and I think
it's put another way I think many asset
managers that we speak to they say that
they actually a lot of their a lot of
their portfolios would not meet the time
taxonomy today they wouldn't pass it
because it's and the question is really
does the does the taxonomy I should
support the transition does it meet the
market where it currently stands or is
it really just governing financial flows
that would have happened anyway is this
a trend that you're seeing that was
actually the taxonomy of significant use
here well I think we of course
stainable phone in action plan if you
want to call it because it connects the
real economy so it evaluates economic
activities with sustainability and and
in the end I mean what deterrence
taxonomy aims to achieve is in the best
case minimize transaction costs build
point of reference for financial market
actors I mean if anything financial
market actors like investors one
standards especially in the bond market
and so the you green bond standard it's
linked to the taxonomy for example so
that's very I think useful and very
welcomed by the financial industry the
point here is that I think you need to
give it a bit more time so you know
we've been developing that I think quite
a fairly short time frame for good
reasons and it is the starting point and
I think a whole ecosystem needs to
involve it wolf around taxonomy so what
I mean by a co system is what mr.
dumbrowsky mentioned for example to add
the other environmentally objective so
whether it's circular economy protection
of maritime borders protection of
biodiversity and so forth and not only
climate mitigation and adaptation while
those obviously are - that need
immediate say attention the other part
is you need to have data providers
because it will take corporates some
time to disclose and again here we have
to think about you know we want more
data we need to give corporates a bit of
time to prepare also to educate
themselves on taxonomy how does it work
what is - no significant harm mean so
you aim to leave the taxonomy objective
but you may harm other objectives
so you mentioned complication is I think
complication is also a matter of
perception
you got to make yourself familiar with
those new developments you got to train
yourself but that must not be
underestimated whether it's us as
investors or corporates ecosystem also
means you need to have verifiers on
taxonomy disclosure
whether they're auditors or user-defined
verifiers I think that's detail and in
the end if everything works out of
course you may achieve what the U and
Britain and many others globally want to
achieve to shift a lot of money into
sustainable investments to facilitate
the transformation which is required if
we turn now to the future and the
requirements that we have going forwards
the amount of money that is supposedly
looking for ESG but specifically for
climate climate and resilient
investments is absolutely enormous and
as a banker I must say ask your question
right as a bank I must say it's very
hard very often to find sufficiently
robust well-defined green projects to
invest in a wind farm is fairly obvious
a solar panel you get beyond that into
the area of housing or manufacturing or
cement or steel some of the big
industries how do you begin to approach
that particularly as a banker there are
trillions required out there how's it
going to come from how are you gonna get
it together yeah good question if I may
also just touch on the point on on
taxonomy and global consistency which is
really important in this area and just a
practitioner point some looking at
HSBC's disclosures we have almost
hundreds of different definitions
disclosure requirements standards pretty
much by each individual country Stock
Exchange and that makes it really
challenging as a multinational to look
at all of these various inconsistent
standards so one one request there is
for greater alignment and there are
projects underway like the corporate
reporting dialogue which brings a number
of sustainability standard setters
together to a line under the framework
of T CFD the climate standards and I
think that alignment is really important
to encourage more disclosure in this
area and then coming to your other
question again it links back to
definitions it's looking for those
opportunities but there will be a mix as
you said some of the very strict green
opportunities
simply straightforward to find we have
international Greenbaum standards with
different sectors on energy efficiency
on renewables so those are available but
what's starting to emerge is also
transition and looking at some of those
transition sectors or harder to abate
sectors and they're the definitions are
much more nuanced and the type of
opportunities are much more nuanced and
so I think that's one thing that I'm
looking to now is analyzing not only the
green but also these transition
opportunities and that's much more
complex
so transition bonds in particular I
guess exactly what do you tax on local
lights green could be yes there was a
recent or the recent a very interesting
issue 40k tankers and this was a for for
new tankers which are moving from 3%
dirty crude to LNG with noxious fume
Kuja and it was categorized as the light
green and if the whole of the shipping
industry took this over it would reduce
again a significant proportion of the
world's percentage of carbon dioxide
emitted because so much of our trade
still gets by sea and that's not going
to change anytime soon so we need
shipping we need a good solution for
shipping that was classified as light
green a little bit controversial because
the four ships were all oil tankers that
a party is clearly a very good source of
energy and yes yeah there may be a
couple of forts on those transition
activities of course it has been also a
part of a picture which has been taken
into account when developing taxonomy so
basically we're looking at sort of say
green activities as we discussed we're
looking also at transition and enabling
activities so transition activities
already mentioned some of the examples
maybe transition activities in energy
intensive sectors like steel or cement
for example which are energy intensive
industries so transition activity there
is a project with emission levels
substantially
below industry average in this case is a
it's okay to help to transition this
energy-intensive sector to become less
polluting because all they still need
steel and cement and there's also well
if you want other kind of transition
activities which may be phased out and
later for example when we now look at
the Paris goes on the reduction of
emissions if we disclose if we displace
call with natural gas it can bring
substantial emission reductions but it
may well be that then natural gases of
fossil fuel will not be part of the
overall picture some decades down the
road and will be aiming at carbon
neutrality but it may help for a
transition period and as regards
enabling activities say-so's wind parks
have been mentioned but then there has
to be factories and and value chains
were those wind farms and turbines and
whatever are being produced so it's in a
sense enabling activity which then
allows us to move from fossil to
renewable energy so they're looking also
at this more more gradual picture if you
want on what is green in a sense already
what is transition what is enabling the
at the end of the day it's gonna be the
banks and the institutions that will
make the make the investments and get
get the finance together so just
remember where the real power lies in
the long run vice-president but Roger it
will be governments who have to be
elected and re-elected yeah yeah
just think about it when you have to
achieve a client goal that is more
ambitious than the average it's gonna be
and you know hope you get there it's
gonna be a glorious harmony between us
all I'm absolutely sure but but 7 could
I particularly its I would like to know
from from your perspective is ESG is it
developing fast enough I'll be getting
enough clarity around the investments
you can make do you feel as an
institutional investors a major
investors so that with with a lot to
contribute going forward do you feel you
have enough opportunity and enough
clarity around the around the room the
ambitions of the investments that you're
able to make so I think one point I'd
like to echo is that obviously with all
the effort around shifting trillions not
millions into green you you have to take
account of the point that any financial
institution only invests when its
convinced about the return in line with
risk so I think that part is important
to highlight so what should not happen
is a pushing somebody into something
that is not performing financially so
everything needs to be balanced so we
have a fiduciary duty as an asset
manager bank has a duty towards its
shareholders not to overload the loan
portfolio with non-performing loans and
so forth so so that needs to be balanced
now I think a point that we're also the
EU and I'm sure Britain is working on is
open up a project stream in the real
economy so I know there is initiatives
so what I think what we need is to open
up a stream of public-private
partnerships so that asset class is
highly interesting you know is aimed at
delivering stable financial returns cash
flows that's what long-term investors
are looking for at moderate risks and we
need substitutes because we are working
in a environment of very low interest
rates if not negative rates right so
there's a win-win if you want to call it
like this but opening up that stream is
important
and so here again here I think what
needs to be avoided is a crowding out of
the market a crawling out where you
shift too much money into a small pocket
of projects and we see this point in in
in in in Europe and other parts of the
world where there has been a yield
compression in for example renewable
energy and what happens is that you know
you've got to be very selective what you
boy in wouldn't or photo will take and
then it's more about quality so just fix
this it's really open up the butch
extreme and encourage corporates to
transform and innovate I think the
innovation and you mentioned a couple of
interesting industries you know it's not
about as much as we need a taxonomy for
green and but I think we as investors
for example you know we just simply look
at a corporate where it is where the
business strategy is and is it
innovating what year of capital
expenditures goes into green products
investments low carbon technology what
share of R&D goes into innovation right
that's the future and you don't know
will be backward-looking you you want to
see where corporate is on the trajectory
towards a low-carbon world the political
signals are extremely clear the
instruments are very helpful coming
forward so taxonomy for example sets an
interesting side product the side
product is if you look at the carbon
efficiency thresholds we define for the
various activities and you can benchmark
your own corporate or an industry where
it's dense
so take auto mobile so taxonomy says 50
gram of carbon dioxide emission per
kilometre if you look at fleet averages
of many carb companies they are at 130
and you know we got the 95 gram coming
forward in 2021 if you don't they're
fine but also with the taxonomy you know
there's a bit of a see it as a risk
signal and how fast you have to
transform and disruption is key and
sustainability disruption also means
automobile sector is a good sector
there's new technology new cars hydrogen
where does it go that in the end as I
said
it is about not threatening corporates
corporates need a bit of time I think
it's very important to talk to
treacherous strategies see the c-suite
incorporates where they are what they
plan what they need and then also we as
investors of course we can go in a
dialogue or we can give positive loans
in the banks I mean reduce the coupon by
achieving sustainability objectives
linked to take some of it for example
thank you very much I'm gonna open up
for questions any moment while I ask and
the ambassador a really mean question
which I would have asked the Prime
Minister if he was here I would well I
lost you question I think the Prime
Minister would appreciate that is Latvia
is also very strong ambitions in the
area of zero carbon how are you going to
pay for it why do you think we are
discussing this now know very clearly I
mean the EU mff next EU mff will be
crucial for us so we will be looking of
course at getting the financing right
what comes what comes from the EU for
what type of projects in what type of
industries we have a strong financial
sector in that phase that is one thing
and they already implement the
sustainability standards by the UN AP
and so on so forth so they are very well
aware is that there will be a major part
from their side also and they smoke so
when we look at the renewables we are
far ahead of the average India already
but we have to move to 40 percent in
2030 so there is a plan there is a very
concrete plan the issue will be
transport especially private transport
the cars you know how do you get to
change user habits which is as much as
you know what what incentives do you use
it once of course energy efficiency is
good so in that respect it will be fine
but but it costs a lot of money so our
national effort EU financing and
industry are the three elements we are
looking at and the industry in a way the
sense because again
what type of loans for what type of
companies will be classified as green
how not to make it too complicated for
the SME is not so impose inadequate
burden to make them flourish how to
involve the civil society so that they
actually support with their knowledge
already on the subject so it's it's a
real network I think it's it's I think
Larry is a sort of laboratory currently
how to how to get it all going so we get
it right I think everybody can get it
right well this if I may
add a couple of points indeed if you
look at the case of Latvia like I
already know has a lowest co2 emissions
per capita in EU 28 and somewhere a
second or third highest share of
renewables in energy mix in EU 28 so I'd
say if the whole you would get as far as
a Latvia we would have been already
quite advanced you see this is meaning
my question to you the opportunity to
point out what a great job latter is
doing and so thank you very much that
I'd like to open up for questions in the
audience if we have some I know that
some of the yes please if you could say
actually if you can say who you are and
your institution and then and then
speaking to microphone yes I'm
interested to know what you think the
biggest gaps are remaining in disclosure
requirements and how they could be fixed
the biggest gaps in disclosure
requirements and how they could be fixed
well on disclosure requirements we
briefly discussed it already in a sense
we seized it currently we are aligned to
large extent on non-binding reporting
so first saying is to make as a
disclosure framework more more binding
then indeed we will be looking how to
expand it across different sector of
different sectors of financial sector
different parts of financial sector and
potentially into also non financial
sector so basically this will be exactly
one of the work streams in a next
sustainable finance action plan which
will be putting forward next year thank
you very much thank you yes silver brush
news vice-president abroad skits in your
remarks he talked about extending
equivalents for access to UK clearing
houses how long will that be extended
for and will it be time limited the
question is how long could the
equipment's be extended for well it's to
be decided currently what I can do now
basically to announce this intentions
that we will be working on this given
the fact that the current equivalents
determination expires and 30th of March
next year but there is another point
which I would like to very much
emphasize its industries preparedness so
one shouldn't expect this being you know
extended and extended and extended again
so there'll be also strong strong focus
on actually industry in doing its part
in mitigating this systemic risks to the
financial stability thank you yes
Kleber disk lived a chance
thank you very much those presentations
I had a question on the taxonomy and the
use potentially in future legislation
we've heard the technical expert
described the taxonomy as a comparative
tool and we've also heard people apply
the standards in terms of transition
financing with a slightly more nuanced
approach whereas often in legislation
the sort of binary approach to in or out
works quite well when you're trying to
you know allocate potentially a green
supporting factor or anything of the
like how do you see the taxonomy being
applied as a as a comparative tool or
more of a binary test I think that's one
for first of all I think taxonomy as a
binary tool is it's probably district so
it is you know to do digital so I think
what we need to accept is that as was
mentioned you know a lot of activities I
mean can be i think clearly put into a
korean bucket there others in between an
on transition so some a comparative
approach benchmarking towards most
efficient practices in a certain
economic activity our our key I know
that that that's been quite an intensive
discussion about you know I think often
misunderstood for example when you
compare taxonomy with science-based
targets that rather ask corporates to
put out a plan how they decarbonize
their business activities in the next
years and how much greenhouse gas they
aim to reduce
I think both are in the end compatible I
think that's misunderstood in their
application the I think the what we have
to see is how the market practice really
involves who wrote that to be honest I
think it's a bit too early but but in
the in the in the end I mean it's its
comparative maybe just expand upon that
because one of the for those of you who
are not familiar with it with the
taxonomy one of the one of the hallmarks
of it is that you it says you should not
banks and institutions should not
disengage with current carbon intensive
industries and simply because they're
carbon intensive so please engage with
them and then persuade that soil to
persuade the transition to go in the
right direction and rather than just
take them out of your portfolios and
stock or lending so BP shall the big
Cement Lafarge
are all to me speaking very interesting
stories about the way they want to see
the their own business go which makes
them part of the transition therefore an
acceptable part of the of the financing
strategy and I should allow you to
comment on this more because but it
seems to me it's a hallmark of the
taxonomy is that it does permit that it
doesn't say just stop financing all but
well first of all to be clear taxonomy
is not compulsory in a way that it's not
prohibited to lend to economic
activities which are not compliant with
the taxonomy so from that point of view
something is there to define what
economic activity is green to facilitate
to shift from from more political
activities to more green activities but
it's not per commission to invest say in
call if someone decides to do so and as
an indeed as this taxonomy has already
discussed is is granule there is
taxonomy which is greens there is
transition activities which are
described what they can be they're
enabling activities so
indeed it's built in it in the ways that
it can support already economic
activities which are if you want aligned
with Paris goals and then beyond
potentially on climate neutrality and
economic activities which help us move
towards that direction thank you thank
you yes
the vice-president mentioned a new
action plan that we should expect
sometime next year and obviously the
Commission has said they will respond to
all the areas that were covered in the
high level report of last year can you
say anything else about the other
elements besides the non-financial
reporting that has already been
discussed that we can expect to see in
this new action plan thank you well
actually already mentioned some of the
elements in my speech maybe to reiterate
some of the points so firstly indeed a
need to finalize the work of taxonomy
because this is a basis for many new
activities so based on taxonomy we can
develop EU green bond standards we can
develop EU eco label for financial
products to start with retail financial
products with potentially to move to
other retail other financial products we
can move to the green mortgages defined
real mortgages for example and see how
we can support those green mortgages
European banking authorities already
assessing well what can be done in terms
of Prudential treatment to support this
Green transition so it's going to be
quite comprehensive action plan
good morning young from mission quad and
my question is about the cooperation
with China what are the opportunities do
you see country like the UK Latvia and
other European countries when China is
promoting further opening up and it's
making more efforts in in the green and
a sustainable development
thank you or maybe to start is at last
part of the question on sustainable
development certainly we see China as an
important partner as a world's second
largest economy and actually the world's
largest emitter of greenhouse gases of
course any global effort to fight
climate change
needs China on board and from this point
of view we welcome China's commitment to
Paris climate change goals we welcome
now China's engagement in international
platform of sustainable finance also to
work in this area of a financial sector
and more general so we continue to work
with China for example towards
investment agreement investment
partnership seeing more opening up in
area of investment
so from the EU side we will continue to
engage closely with China I might also
mention the EU and London have been
working together with China through the
Green Finance Committee they're both on
shared standards on implementation of
tea safety and particularly on the green
investment principles for the belphin
Road which has been a major piece of
work which now has some 35 banks and
institutions signed up for to these
green investment principles and that's
been something we've been thank you very
much mark Latvian honorary consul in
Hartford sure question about brexit
which we've managed to avoid so far the
British government's made clear
to diverge from European Union standards
after it leaves the European Union is
this an area where Britain should seek
to be as closely aligned as possible or
to go it its own way and if it is to be
aligned how is this to be achieved with
button being outside of the formal
mechanisms of the European Union also
well yes I would say we have outlined
the EU approach to this issue already in
quite some detail so first we would rely
on system of equivalents determinations
between EU and UK in the area of
financial services well it's sector by
sector its legislation by association
its unilateral so that both sides
preserves regulatory autonomy so those
principles have been outlined already
then I would say in terms of those
equivalences it should not be overly
complicated a given that we start from
the same point because currently EU
legislation is in place in UK so from
that point of view if UK does not engage
in deregulation or starts shifting away
from EU s regulatory framework that is I
would say completely feasible basis for
work at the same time we have outlined
also --use approach on equivalence so a
couple of elements which are important
first that we see it is a as a granule
approach so in a sense
if markets are of more systemic
importance for the EU we expect a larger
degree of alignment with the EU so it's
we must see what kind of potential
systemic risks are risks to financial
stability we are in a sense potentially
importing through equivalent
determination so the more systemic say
relationship the closer alignment we
would expect and second that in terms of
equivalence determinations we also have
a framework on so to say ex-post
monitoring of compliance with
equivalence conditions so in a sense if
we have equivalence in certain area and
later well the third country decides to
diverge regulatory or is not following
up with the developments in EU we can
withdraw was ethical and actually there
had been in a last couple of months of
first presidents where we had actually
doing so were third countries were not
following the regulatory developments in
the EU so that's a basic approach how we
intend to cooperate in the area of
financial services thank you you've got
time for two last questions I think I'll
take them together from a1 here and back
tom burke from III g achieving a net
zero europe by around the middle of the
century means that effectively will have
stopped burning gas that means will have
stopped importing russian gas is that
good for bad for European security and
shouldn't we perhaps be also thinking
about strengthening our relationship on
decarbonization with Russia as well as
China well indeed once we move to the
carbon no natural economy fossil fuels
will not be part of the picture so as we
were discussing before natural gas
plates roll in transition towards carbon
natural economy we are shifting for more
polluting natural fossil fuels like coal
for example but eventually we would move
out those fossil fuels including natural
gas in fact for example European
Investment Bank just a couple of days
ago if not yesterday when was it
announced that as of if I'm not mistaken
2021 it will not further invest in
natural gas so in a sense we see that
banks are already moving away from
natural gas and as one of the reasons of
what ARB was putting forward is the risk
of stranded assets that they do not want
to invest in assets which can
potentially can get stranded as EU
continues to the carbon isaacs economy
also you know we look at the inside you
are specifically a Russian gas obviously
there are two securities so for us it
was not only you know there's a fossil
fossil energy and the energy mix but
also the security so there is a larger
aim always in diversification and moving
to renewables so that was a choice that
laffy made heard Commission officials
talked about the taxonomy must be based
in science but have political consensus
and also work with the grain of the
market so three conditions but they
could be contradictory and are thinking
of nuclear I mean the science says one
thing and the politics in some countries
says another which would win out in the
inner debate nuclear power
and clearly when building a taxonomy
again that evaluates real economic
activities and technologies to be
personalized you get it
stretch points so guess was one I think
even the one that probably was not as
reflected as strongly as nuclear power
in the media but it's the bigger one a
nuclear power of course we have a as you
know different opinions between member
states sure I mean there is no golden
answer to it I mean it's a negotiation
process in the end I mean there will be
legislation coming forward that will be
driven by the member states in the
council which I cannot comment it's a
political process and should that
comment I mean what what what happens I
think what I would I say from an
investment perspective and somebody who
uses the taxonomy going forward for
financial products is that I expect it
to be dynamic so taxonomy is not carved
in stone you know and there will be
whether it's nuclear power currently the
attention there will be other
technologies like carbon capture storage
pressuring carbon dioxide into the
ground is also another technology that's
heavily debated whether it produces
positive effects or negative effect we
will always have this this is in the
nature of taxonomies
so I think what what will happen is
there is a dynamics around it there's a
continuous technology progress and again
I know that that people in the energy
industry they point at all the
innovation in energy power but still you
know how to fix say the waste side of
nuclear power is not properly solved yet
so you you can argue back and forth and
and there will be trade-offs and there
is no yes/no answer in my view it will
be dynamic and that's the nature of
taxonomy on that note I think
unfortunately have to finish could
you've run out of time and thank you
very much my supposed to thank you
ambassador Thank You Rebecca thank you
Stephanie very much do you for
participating this there's a lots more
to
and there's lots more to take forward so
if we could say around of course
just before everybody leaves as policy
chair at the City of London Corporation
it falls to be just say final few words
to round this morning off we've been
very pleased to hold this here this
morning and delighted to see all of you
in the audience but a particular thanks
to our speakers today and to the panel
for that very interesting discussion
just now of course we're fully aware
that the relationship between the UK and
the EU is is going to change and right
in the middle of this election campaign
it's perhaps even more uncertain if
that's possible to know what the future
relationship will be like than it is
when our Parliament is actually sitting
but whatever whatever happens whatever
happens and we recognize the importance
of continued cooperation and engagement
between the UK and the EU and in that
context and can I warmly welcome your
announcement vice president on the
question of temporary equivalents for UK
clearinghouses what you've said about
extension will be very good news for UK
but for the financial sector generally
and for the 14 trade associations some
represented in this room who wrote to
you on this very important issue just
yesterday I think we all recognize the
need to be realistic about financial
stability and about the need for
preparedness and so your comments just
now will have been well taken and and
heard and cooperation and engagement is
of course going to be very important
also on the key questions that we've
been discussing this morning
particularly around sustainability and
green growth global challenges which are
going to require international
cooperation that at European level as
well as at global level for us all to
meet and we're absolutely determined
here in the city to play our part this
is of course a city and a sector which
has a strong track record in this area
with the stock exchange
having seen the first issuance of the
London Stock Exchange having seen the
first issuance of certified green bond
and numerous other developments here in
the market that's why we helped Treasury
to set up the green finance Institute
earlier this year at which Roger chairs
to champion sustainable finance in the
UK and beyond we want the city to become
an engine of the transition to a
low-carbon economy
a global hub for green investment and
also for green arbitration and Counting
and technology but in all that it's
absolutely vitally important that we
work in partnership across borders that
to go back to your comments ambassador
we don't have silos in this important
area and we hope that continuing to work
with Latvia and with our other EU
partners will help to contribute to a
shared approach at global level so that
we can really work together to meet the
challenges but also to take advantage of
the opportunities for sustainable growth
across Europe so another thanks to our
panel and thank you all for coming thank
you
[Applause]